a book which has been getting a fair
amount of attention over the last couple
of weeks it's a biography of bin Laden
the man who declared war on America
Yosef Modjeski is joining us thanks for
being with us sir
in the book you write he is not an evil
lone ranger but rather a principle
player in a tangled and sinister web of
terrorism sponsored States intelligence
chieftains and master terrorists
together they wield tremendous power
throughout the Muslim world and wreak
havoc and devastation upon their foes
how did he get to this point how did he
get to this point he's always been a
team player
he joined when he joined a jihad in
Afghanistan in the early 1980s he went
in to support an action that was
unfolding he identified there was an was
adopted by the time the key ideological
leader of the extremist jihad Mohammed
Azam and he relied on him in order to
build his connections and contacts in he
never kind of tried to elbow his way to
the top the same thing he did when he
was in Sudan under the hasanul to AH be
the spiritual leader of the country who
is one of the great luminaries of modern
Islam and currently in Afghanistan he
makes friends with everybody you also
write that this declaration of holy war
is not an empty gesture bin Laden hates
the United States passionately and
considers it his principal enemy why
because bin Laden believes that with the
collapse of core not just him but the
entire body call Islam movement believe
that with the collapse of communism
Islam as they perceive it as a political
movement has a chance to conform
capitalism and establish a new Cold War
relationship in which Islam eventually
triumphs altima however the spread of
Western influence Western culture
electronic media etcetera etcetera into
Islam Dome the dependence on high tech
from the West all of that demonstrate to
them that Islam is failing and therefore
there is no other way but to instigate a
global war through provoking the west by
spectacular acts of terrorism of the car
we've seen in New York and in the
Pentagon when did you first become
interested in
sama bin Laden Oh back in 81 this book
came out when the the hardcover came out
in the summer of 99 and in doing
research what what did you learn that in
trade you the most about this man is
brilliant he and he understand what is
happening in the world
his very learn at the individual is very
pragmatic individual he knows his
limitations he knows his strengths he
know de strengths and limitations of its
allies and is making the best out of it
and he's uncompromising take us through
his life where and when was he born as
he moved into adulthood what was he
doing in his 20s and 30s he was born in
the mid 50s in Saudi Arabia to a very
affluent family very well-connected
family self-made family from a Yemenite
background he is that was very close to
the royal family got a westernized
education which is very important he
knows the worst and he knows what he has
rejected and what he is confronting was
influenced by the family return to Islam
in early nineteen our traditional Islam
in early 1980s went to Afghanistan spend
the decade fighting and primarily
facilitating the logistical support and
infrastructure build-up of the
resistance which enabled them to sustain
operation against the Soviet for a long
time I mean his contribution was crucial
returned to Saudi Arabia a hero but
confronted the royal family over the
question of presence of Western troops
in Saudi Arabia during the Gulf War was
exiled to Sudan where he became a to
things happened to him in Sudan when he
became the protégé of hassan al nabi
which build him spiritually
ideologically theologically number two
we got to know Ayman al-zawahiri who is
now his right-hand man and cue military
commander in 1996 moved to Afghanistan
and started building his own presence
his own entity within the Islamist
movement which made him today the most
popular individual in the Muslim world
at the street level no question about it
so he's now in his mid 40s is in mid
forties is his mom alive
his dad alive his mother is dead his
father died in
aircraft are fresh around 1970 his
adopting mother and other wife of his
father that essentially brought him up
is living right now Latakia Syria with
the rest of the family protected by
Syrian intelligence from our retribution
how many siblings Oh around fifty
sixteen what the count is not that
complaint fifty to sixty no not his I
mean here's our brothers about 50-60
brothers here but fifteen sixteen
seventeen children and how many wives
just a summer been one half that is
another debatable issue Islam commits an
individual to marry four wives so it has
for a while but he had actually six
women that he has rotated over the years
so he divorced two and still has two
before and why is religion such a
passion for him it's not religion is
power Islamism is a political power it's
not based on the teaching of Islam is
they interpret it and you'll have a lot
of Muslim scholars coming and arguing
that this is not Islam in the purest
form but Islamism is a political power
it's a quest and lust for power
dominance over over others we go back to
the book and you write an event that
happened in 1973 Muhammad bin Laden was
deeply affected spiritually when he
rebuilt and refurbished the two holy
mosques and these changes gradually
affected Osama right what were you
writing about his father's company was
asked to to be dominant in the
rebuilding of Islam's holy shrines and
that gave Osama bin Laden access to the
shrine as well as to the various key
religious luminaries supervising the act
and he became a traditionalist
increasing increasingly traditionalist
but but again the switch was not
immediate it was by conviction took him
time to move away from the West and into
traditionalist Islam
our guest is Joe Sabo danske who has a
book out on Osama bin Laden came out in
1999 this is the paperback edition
our phone lines are open we have divided
the lines regionally two zero two seven
three seven triple zero one if you live
in the eastern and central time zones if
you're in the mountain Pacific time
zones the numbers to zero to seven
37000 two and we have one line set aside
for arab-americans at two zero two six
two eight oh two oh five moving along
chronologically in the 1980s you write
in the early 80s the situation had
changed in both Pakistan and Afghanistan
soon after the invasion the Soviets
seized the military initiative and they
did not lose it lose it until the
withdrawal of the Soviets in 1989 the
resistance could not prevent the Soviet
forces from doing whatever they wanted
in Afghanistan why so because the
resistance was incapable of confronting
confronting the Soviets of the town
forces it was not strong militarily
there's never been an effort on our part
or our allies part to enable the
resistant to seize power and sustain
power all we wanted essential is to
contain the Soviet Union in Afghanistan
so it does not reach the Persian Gulf in
the Indian Ocean and we succeeded in
doing that we did so on the back of the
Afghans and we still paying the price of
that how did somebody from Saudi Arabia
end up as a friend I guess you call him
a friend of the Taliban regime in
Afghanistan or supporter of the Taliban
regime the Taliban is is a Pakistani
created outgrowth by hell pushing to the
extreme of the resistance movement that
we have supported and sustained among
other thing was Saudi money during the
nineteen eighty they're not something
that came out of the blue it's just that
they've taken the extremism their
extremism a little bit beyond acceptable
however the many of the Mujahideen that
we supported is great freedom fighters
during the nineteen eighty like go but
in fact Mattia were not that much
different than the Taliban let's get a
call from Baltimore good morning you're
in c-span good morning uh first of all
just wanted to thank c-span you've had
some terrific guests on today this
gentleman is certainly included in that
I have a comment this morning and I'd
like to see if the gentleman concurs
first of all you made a great point
about some of in Laden and al Qaeda
being about power
more so than religion I think that
that's a point that needs to be hammered
home in the press my comment is much of
this talk has been about understanding
the aims or the goals of these groups
whether it be about Palestine whether it
be getting the US military presence out
of Saudi Arabia
my point would be even if these things
were attained even if there was a an
established Palestinian state even if
the United States removed its troops
from from all Muslim lands I don't think
that bin Laden or his group would be
satisfied I think that their goals are
like he said their goals are for power
their goals are for obviously creating
terror creating as he said a new cold
war and I would like to know if he
agrees with this that there really isn't
an established goal other than then
continuing the fight against the West
Thank You caller
yeah the caller is absolutely right bin
Laden the current crisis that we're
facing in the aftermath of the terrorist
strike in New York and the Pentagon is
has been building geologically and
ideologically since 1999 when be not in
published a major booklet and the titled
America and the third world war in which
bin Laden outlined the need for a global
confrontation a fateful uncompromising
confrontation between Islam and the West
over the future of Islam is a political
movement and at that in that book and in
subsequent writings that further
elaborated on the point he said that a
the outcome of that regime of that war
will be this reestablishment of the
Caliphate a single Muslim state capable
of dominating the world and number two
that the only weight in order to get the
West into that kind of a confrontation
one has to provoke the west through
spectacular acts of terrorism that the
West cannot ignore or swallow and will
move into a major war and that exactly
what we've seen do you have any
speculation on when and where Osama bin
Laden recorded this taped address that
aired on the network's yesterday he
recorded it probably a few days ago I
would say somewhere between October 5th
and October 7 and in one of his hideout
in central Afghanistan as the the date
is determined on the basis of the
dissemination of comparable notes
throughout the Muslim world that were
dated accordingly how did he look
physically to you very good I mean is is
graying but we all
but other than that is in good shape
given that the hardship of his life is
definitely in good shape and what is
life like inside these tents what type
of in this care our camps and caves very
very spot on be nothing have one central
cave in the Jalalabad area where he has
a wonderful wonderful library of classic
Islamic literature religious literature
but very Spartan living condition filled
beds small blankets very little food a
lot of weapons no running water no
hitting or nothing no creature comforts
have you met Osama bin Laden no next
call is from New York City go ahead
you're on c-span good morning you know
how one good morning caller yeah hi how
are you I'm an Arab American I think I
think it is very difficult when someone
write the book and does not really know
very much about the Arabs especially
Muslims it's very difficult for me like
um
United States actually made the some of
the Latin very here the biggest here on
the planet where if they dress the issue
he will never become a hero because a
lot of issues like we discussed today in
the United State is go back to a very
big root thanks color I don't think you
do United State made the summer be
landing the most popular men today in
the Muslim world it is the plight of the
Muslim world and if you look for example
at something as statistic that the
French did the two most popular names
were given two baby boys today
throughout the Muslim world are Mohammed
for the Prophet and Osama for Osama bin
Laden he is elucidate the flight of the
Muslim world the problems on confronting
the West economic decline etcetera
etcetera etc problem is that he then
takes it from there into a twisted
version of his extremist Islam that does
not represent the opinion of the vast
majority of people or the aspirations
which is to live
peacefully with the west and benefit
from what the West has to offer
economically and here we face
essentially the danger that we face
today as we go and confront Afghanistan
modern constitute quarter of humanity
bin Laden's hardcore supporters
constitute about quarter of a million
and we have to be very very careful to
make sure that our war with this quarter
of a million does not transform it you
know into a crusade again the needless
crusade against a quarter of humanity
you write about Somalia why was that
significant in his struggle to to gain
power in Somalia he was a key supporter
been ours our here with the key military
guy involved that was the first jihad
that he ran under to habían under the
principle of hassan al to hobby and he
proved that he can do it
it could be trusted and i think that was
the boost that sent him to the top it
was also the first major intervention in
offensive intervention in a war against
America in order to contain the spread
of US influence into areas claimed by
the Slovaks we saw two bombings at
embassies one in dar Salam in Africa it
was Bobby in the other and I Roby who is
behind that urban audience through his
choice Network the issue if you go into
legalese bin Laden has always kept a
certain gap of deniability so that it
cannot be legally charged with
instigation of of the actual terrorist
operation he did inspire them he did
guide and created the framework under
which the the perpetrator operated
knowing that they've doing God works
quote unquote
in blowing up beat the World Trade
Center all the embassies in East Africa
if we go into actual specific operation
we have to remember that this operation
would not have been possible without the
key support from the sponsoring States
because the nudding inspires the
sponsoring states enabled them to carry
out the operation provide the where we
done yosef Podolski is our guest he has
a book out on Osama bin Laden called the
man who declared war on America next
call is from Sunnyvale California good
morning
good morning good morning caller morning
yeah hi good morning to you good
yeah hi I'm here go ahead with your
question or I'm going to move to another
call
my question to you is this Yousef can
you hear me yes yeah good is it do you
think that the administration has a
successive administration has a lot to
do with what's happening today because
they they're there in inaction in the
past for not doing anybody terrorist in
the past what generated that tax on the
11th of September semester if I
understand your point Haller well the
point is this that we have had a lot of
warning in the past and we got to war
what is going to happen to America and
nobody to gain notice in the past there
were no specific warnings that could
have been acted upon in order to prevent
the attacks of September 11 if you
remember during the Millennium period
there were a lot of warnings and many
many terrorist operations have been
preempted and prevented by the security
authority of the United States and by
our allies back to the book page 313
from his cave headquarters bin Laden
supervises a tangled web of financial
entities both his own and those filling
the coffers of the Islamic movement he
also handles the Foreign Assets of the
Taliban movement there is no distinct
distinction between Osama bin Laden
instead bin Laden maintains a tangled
web of companies partnerships and other
named entities that interact with one
another and are ultimately concealed in
another layer of bigger international
finance financial entities so that his
involvement in any of these investments
cannot be discovered how does he do that
from the wonders of electronic media
Computers supervises his own people
actually do the legwork for him the idea
was to develop the concept
of the building shells upon shell
function layers upon layers upon layers
of accompanies to which you run the
money the other thing that he does with
the money is using organized crime you
know the two localized organized crime
in order to conceal the money within the
ranks of all the laundering of the money
within the ranks of criminal activity so
that if anything is exposed the security
authorities look at it as yet another
criminal venture as opposed to terrorist
presence you also write that bin Laden
and his followers are very serious about
the use of chemical and biological
weapons in future strikes already in the
summer of 98 senior field commandos of
the Islamic Front were aware of the
availability of chemical weapons and the
specific contingency plans for their use
right der service weapons of mass
destruction of legitimate weapons as far
as the Islamists are concerned because
they're supposed to deliver results that
no other weapons can Columbus Georgia
good morning good morning a bit and the
US for 40 years now were you from
originally Afghanistan and I've been to
India but I disagree with the military
action being taken and I do agree
because the seeds of saying must be
destroyed I'm a Christian and how do you
destroy those seeds of Satan that's the
military action towards the Taliban I
hate
those people because I have family that
still live in India and they have to get
a fan so let me be clear about this you
hate the Taliban regime or you hate the
American use of force in Afghanistan
I don't want innocent people harmed in
Afghanistan but the fourth aney the
necessary force needs to be done to get
the terrorists I understand
but since I have family in Afghanistan
and India
I don't like the cities' people yes yeah
killed okay thanks for the call Josefa
danske response of course as I said we
need to make sure that we do not
transform through our action needlessly
transform innocent parts of the Muslim
world into inflexible enemies I think
true selective use of force through
other covert clandestine and a non
military action we can make sure of that
if we just pay attention to it and be
very very careful in selecting targets
and means and methods for implementing
god president's directives do you know
where the name Taliban comes from here
the students are students in mothers or
religious schools in Pakistan where the
leadership of the Taliban fault us
sought and received shelter when the
resistance started collapse collapsing
in the late 1980s and have been there
until the Pakistanis needed them to fill
in a void in the leadership in the south
eastern and southern parts of
Afghanistan and followed them and the
rest is history
a viewer from Sterling Virginia please
ask mr. Buddha ask you why there is so
little attention being paid to Osama bin
Laden's connection to the Balkans
specifically through the Mujahideen in
Bosnia and the Kosovo Liberation Army in
Kosovo I don't know why this little
attention has been has been put in the
media perhaps because we've been
supporting the very same people that
including use of arms very same people
who have been not in service from the
very beginning however it should be said
that
from the late 1980s even before before
Bosnia surged into so-called
independence the Islamic leadership
within bosnia have been closer ties with
the extremist or bin laden's many have
been through the same training camps
they received tremendous amount of
support from the Islamist movement
including bin Laden's and Ayman
al-zawahiri same thing should be said
about the various Albanians liberation
movement both in Kosovo and Macedonia
and inside Yugoslavia itself from the
New York Post this morning pointing out
that he has reportedly been on the run
moving from hideout to hideout in
Afghanistan how many locations does he
have do you know we know about six
locations well forty five sets of caves
very deep caves well-shielded were
protected against airpower
modern airport including guided
munitions we've designed it we helped
with the funding we supervise the
implementation to Pakistani intelligence
and the Saudis these are very very good
shelters and they've been improved since
then and we did this during the 1980s
early jr. during nineteen nineties the
84 to 86 36 the resistance was on the
verge of collapse and it was imperative
to build islands of sustenance that they
will be able to hold even though the
lines of communication with Pakistan
were breaking bin Laden oversaw the
building of these shelters these islands
of support and well is now using them
best call from Los Angeles good morning
good morning can you hear me Fisher Gail
um I believe that Islam is I'm a
Christian I believe that Islam is a
peaceful religion and if you say they
represent a quarter of humanity they're
all over the globe but many of them are
living captives of tyrants like the
Taliban or like Saddam Hussein like the
medicine for oil exchange with Saddam
they never get any of that medicine bin
Laden refers to a million Iraqi babies
dying because of the u.s. foreign policy
it's simply because the Iraqis are not
informed because all that is kept from
them in the same way that the Afghani
don't know what's going on because it's
they're not allowed to have radio
television can we not after the bombing
is over change our foreign policy
address all these legitimate I believe
complaints that bin Laden has whether or
not it's for his own end or he really is
the hero humanitarian whether he really
cares or not
why don't we address their problems like
help them to understand what's going on
now not propaganda better education
there ought to be a very delicate
balance between running foreign policy
with the with the recognized governments
of a country and intervention in the
internal affair of that country whether
we like specific human rights conditions
economic conditions or any other form of
behavior we should be very careful to
struck the right kind of balance between
interventionism and between legitimate
relationship with with legal government
the modern world does have tremendous
amount of grievances justified
grievances visit with the West but I
think we can and we should work together
with the local governments as opposed to
go in and overthrow regime the sole
exception where we should go after the
leadership's is is all the terrorism
sponsoring states these lawless
government that considered blowing up
buildings in the middle of the United
States a legitimate form of statecraft
cannot and do not have a reason to
continue functioning if you could know
somebody asked yeah like you look at the
screen a map of the region if you give
us a sense give our viewers a sense of
the support that we have around
Afghanistan and which countries will
have the most trouble with over the next
few weeks
well we should look differently we have
first of all the tourism sponsoring
states the the committed countries are
committed to confrontation with the
United States ideologically and this was
the primary of Syria Iraq in Iran on one
hand Pakistan has been a tourism
sponsoring state until recently and
question is to what extent does the
current change of heart
is a result of our pressure and
realizing that the world has changed or
a general change of heart one should
hope that it's a genuine change of heart
Sudan made a lot of noises of moving
back in the right direction by the day
after the sanctions have been lifted
they released Hassan dr. Wahby from his
incarceration so one question their
sincerity on the Allied side we have
Israel where Saudi Arabia of course
where the Gulf states we have Amanda
provide the British with a lot of bases
where the Yemen that is a de facto
hostile State given the strength of pro
hockey programming forces in its rank at
the Islamic movement and on the east we
have India staunch ally that has been
itself a victim of Pakistani sponsored
war by proxy and international terrorism
China is a very complex country because
under one hand it does suffer from
Islamist terrorism in Xinjiang in the
western provinces but on the other hand
it is strongest strong al our Pakistan
entry to sponsor of Islamic subversion
throughout Central Asia the Central
Asian government are very unstable
we need Russian assistance in order to
stabilize them and use their
infrastructure against Afghanistan
they're all victims of Islamic terrorism
coming from Pakistan and Afghanistan and
therefore have vested interest in
helping us and then we go all the way to
Chechnya and and the Caucasus which is
another hotbed of Islamic surveillance
the threatens regional stability and
does the Taliban regime of Afghanistan
have any allies they used to have allies
in Saudi Arabia because of religious
affinity because the Taliban's ideology
look at again twisting manipulation of
Wahabi
them as the basis and the closest ally
today's Pakistan Pakistan centrally
created the Taliban empowered diamonds
had been sustaining them until the
recent outrages in New York next call is
from Rutherford New Jersey good morning
good morning how you do we talk of a lot
about our Islamic extremists can you
tell me three points that an extremist
believes in that is different and which
separates or some of the same and
Taliban from an everyday Islamic
believer there's one major point and
that is that Islam provide justification
for a surfing of power controlling other
people interfering with other people's
way of life and that in order that in
order to implement that its quest for
power and dominance 100 justification to
kill innocent people at the heart of an
innocent country beat the United States
or any other place in the world this is
not Islam the religion this is a quest
for power that using Islamic terms as a
banner of justification you write that
bin Laden's threat is being a cog albeit
an important one in a large system that
will outlast his own demise
state-sponsored international terrorism
there is indication that says that he
expects to die as a martyr for his cause
if he were to die who would pick up the
pieces
Oh theologically there will not be a
need for somebody to come in replace him
there were big thousands and thousands
and thousands of people standing in line
to fill in the shoes and take revenge in
his name the military council around him
is very strong is very redundant and
resilient and will withstand his demise
he is key important yet important here
two key fields of importance one is
geologically the elucidation of the
message and that is done in 1999-2000
and since then has been elaborating and
refining something that is there the
other one is the relationship between
being the cause of the linchpin between
the lynchpin between the sponsoring
state and the various Islamist movement
worldwide but he is not alone he has
built the whole headquarters of stuff
too
sustain it and if it if it dies they
will be able to continue and sustain it
because the sponsoring states are also
very sophisticated in their dealing with
bin Laden's people in madmen ears people
and the various terrorist movement
underneath and you conclude your book
and we should point out this came out
two years ago the availability of
weapons of mass destruction and the
audacity to reach in into the heart of
the United States will make this trend
all the more frightening it is he's been
writing about it has not been making any
secret about his determination to blow
up something great in the United States
he said that there is a need for
spectacular act of terrorism are not
religious act of terrorism in order to
instigate the world war three the team
aspires for Arlington Virginia good
morning good morning hello good morning
caller good morning hello caller we'll
move on Iowa City good morning to you
caller hello go ahead please yes Thank
You mr. boudin ski you dismissed rather
abruptly an Arab gentleman question
about the root causes of this I
understand that your focus is on bin
Laden here but I really would like you
to try to address more thoughtfully the
fact that there are millions of Arabs
throughout the world of moderate
understanding of great desire for their
situation to be bettered and the United
States is seen by many of them in
Palestine in Iraq and elsewhere as to
some extent being responsible for their
condition and I think many people would
agree that that's the case until we
address these social problems in the
United States from our foreign policy
this will not change okay let's let's
stop it's a complex question yes they
are justified grievances throughout the
Muslim world but they are a result of
lack of development and lack of
willingness of the local regimes to
empower the population
economic development education health
services etc etc rather than the
oppression of the United States so we
should not feel ourselves guilty for
most of the plight of the Muslim world
it is the government's there to do it
number two as far as issues like
Palestine I think there's a tremendous
amount of propaganda surrounding the
situation not it is a desirable
situation you should continue this way
if you look at bin Laden's writing and
we're talking about bin Laden to the
Islamist movement right now in their
writing Israel is being referred to as
the illegitimate offspring of the Great
Satan I Israeli suffering for the
helping the United States in a region
claimed by bin Laden's and his people as
opposed to oppressing the Palestinians
and Israeli suffering for us grievances
in the Muslim world should be addressed
the Muslim world should be helped into
the 21st century as I said we should not
make quarter of humanity our enemies
this is absolutely true but this is not
this has nothing to do with their bin
Laden's of the world this is a small
minority of extremists power-hungry
individual ruthless individual who think
that the existence of grievances give
them the right to Glaus building in the
middle of neo whatever the grievances of
a government of a people they do not
give them the right to blow up a
building and kill innocent civilians at
the heart of another country this is
unacceptable how big is this network it
is a hot course about quarter of a
million people's support system another
two millions there about two two and a
half million it is spread all over the
world
it has riches into the heart it is
hardly a country in the world would they
do not where they're not present in in
an operational form and how much is
Osama bin Laden worth personally zero he
controls certain assets that he donated
to the jihad direct indirectly he does
not the monitory see becomes the less
directly get involved in order not to
contaminate of ongoing operations and
create a web of deniability on an annual
basis he controls
slightly over a billion dollar income
from the drugs of Afghanistan
which is being usually laundered and
rotated through organized crime in the
West and Russian organized crime so that
it's very difficult to put in a hand on
it there's in a neighborhood of several
hundreds of few hundreds of millions of
dollars contribution from Gulf states
that are being used where legal money is
required to charities and things like
that and then rotated and laundered
there's the web of businesses etcetera
that just run money throughout the West
so that there's clean money legitimate
money or laundered money available for
operations without the need to run white
wire transfers etc unless they want to
be identified you write about this and
let me again point out from the map Iran
which borders Afghanistan and Pakistan
did the instability that we saw with the
fall of the Shah and the rise of
Khomeini in the late 1970's and early
80's play into Osama bin Laden's rise to
this support that he has today the
Iranian Revolution - the two things that
formulated the Muslim world today I mean
from political point of view it's the
fall of the shine Iran and the invasion
of Afghanistan in fall of Iran an
Islamist movement succeeded to overthrow
one of the darlings of the United States
in it crucial in a region of crucial
strategic significant economic
significance for the Western we
tolerated it and they came and it took
on the Great Satan humiliated us with
the seizure of the US Embassy in Tehran
etcetera etcetera and created at the
same time a network of training of the
terrorism preparing terrorism for the
entire world to perpetuate the Islamic
Revolution in Afghanistan the Muslim
nations rose against the Soviet Union
the other block of the Cold War and
again succeeded to contain them and
Afghanistan has become what Spain became
to the great causes of the pre-world War
two ERA the book is called bin Laden bin
Laden the man who declared war on
America Iosefa danske is our guest next
call is Ashland Ohio good morning caller
good morning Dallas Texas good morning
to you good morning I had a question
concerning
the authority and his personal opinion
as to a solution just as David Letterman
has a top 10 list he provides every
night what would be this author's top 5
solutions that he would personally
engage in action to provide a solution
as he being authority on the subject
thanks caller:thank well unfortunately
since I have another health and this is
a director of a congressional task force
I'm not at liberty to identify solution
so that my other hat does what is your
background where were you born where you
go to school
born in Israel been involved almost 30
years now altogether in these subjects
we've got to the United States about 20
years ago taught in Johns Hopkins School
of Advanced International Studies did
some work for Pentagon and sir
Department and have been in this
capacity director of the Task Force on
terrorism and unconventional warfare
since I think 1988 what is al Qaeda al
Qaeda ISM is a myth it's a big big tent
with no walls no doors no windows it's
it's a moving ground for a lot of
like-minded people that can associate
themselves with a greater cause they do
not have operational capabilities or
financial capabilities they're not an
organization the vague entity terrorist
operations are being grounded the high
quality terrorist operations of the
condit we've seen and we should worry
about a run by very small highly
centralized network control jointly by
intelligence services of the sponsoring
states and supervised by bin Laden's
keep people like I'm onyx our hearing
desk all from Sedona Arizona good
morning you're on c-span hi if the
muddin is caught
how would how would we deal with him
number one who would let me state the
first point we were getting some echo if
you're able to get through we should
point out please turn the volume down
that's why there's a little bit of a
delay and some echo so that we can hear
clearly your call and question we ask
you to do so I'll answer that the
likelihood of our catching belonging
alive is is very very as low bin Laden
has made he is core bodyguards 120
people 30 of them hardcore loyalists
have been with him since the 1980s and
under the command of his own son
Muhammad to swear and to vowed to him
that if the bed God the enemy closes in
on them they shoot him and kill him so
that he has never been taken alive bin
Laden essentially prepared himself to
die in combat back in the early 1980s
once he went into the forward areas of
Afghanistan and mentally he's been
living on borrowed time ever since his
eager and ready to die on a moment's
notice should the need arise so we're
more likely to catch him dead than alive
we keep hearing about this mountainous
terrain in the caves that he has
burrowed himself and his family and his
supporters inside there's no way
American weapons can get inside those
caves is that what you're saying yeah we
will have to walk our way into them
that's a Special Forces operations the
soviets acceded to take one set of caves
in jawar in the late 1980s 87 if my
memory doesn't Fermi and it was a
tremendously costly operations in human
lives very bitter fighting how many
forces are there in the Taliban regime
that would support Osama bin Laden it's
not so much supporting Osama bin Laden
as much as supporting the Chieftains and
making sure that no foreigners intrude
on the land next call is Fort Lee New
Jersey good morning
yes to questions do you think that what
role if any do you think that Israel
might be playing and in on an
intelligence level in this operation
and on a second level do you think that
Osama bin Laden has any plans to link
Israel into this crisis together with
the United States okay that the first
thing Israel offered the United States
aid in one word everything you need and
I think that Israel has been a staunch
ally and provider of supporting our
intelligence and other means from the
very beginning of the fight against
terrorism and will continue to do so and
the list said about that the better it
is
as far as bin Laden's linking Israel be
nothing has linked Israel from the very
beginning and but not it Palestine and
crisis is a cause for disenchantment
toward the Muslim world but Israel's
being the outpost of Western interests a
stabilizing factor in the Middle East
and as I said before bin Laden's and
Islamist literature call Israel the
illegitimate offspring of the Great
Satan in our midst ie Israel represent
Western interest in areas claimed by
Islam how did you go about researching
this book as a sort of met I learned
about bin Laden in the early 1990s 81-82
from a friend was an Arab friend was in
Afghanistan with her with the resistance
he said that if he doesn't die soon
he'll make history and I got of course
very curious and started following him
I've read a lot of materiality and his
allies afoot I've talked a lot too many
people been involved with him some of
his work closes net and talked to a lot
of people who've been fighting against
him and from all of that combined the
book was it easy or difficult to do a
biography on somebody that you have not
met and did not interview no it wasn't
that difficult to talk to them
I've known enough about him I've read
enough of his work and read transcript
of conversation that he had with his own
lieutenants as opposed to interviews
with Western correspondents that to get
to realize them and the second thing yes
this is a biography of bin Laden but
this is also the story of the slums
that he inspires and leads and that
involves other people he is a team
player all the way to the end and they
are also covered in it
is there anything significant about his
name know that the name he was given is
it a common name
note that what is its line is it's a
lion cub that surges it's a very
assertive name next call Hampton
Virginia good morning yes I like to ask
if the news network still haven't
addressed about the sanity of this guy
and does he really think that he wants
to reignite the Crusades
and have the Christian world against the
Muslim world
what is your viewpoint on this oh the
man is uh is perfectly sane is committed
to a cause or to an extremist cause but
yes his logic elucidates his logic
explain why he does it he knows de the
risk and entailed for himself and for
the Muslim world
he has defined the parameters of the
struggle of the jihad in in the most
clear way his writing his F are
excellent a very loose is very logical
his Arabic is flowery and wonderful his
use of citations from both the Koran and
the writings of luminaries of of Islam
are accurate correct Amin is not
manipulating text is making a very very
good logical case for for his more
ideology for his call to arms Alexandria
Virginia good morning
you're on c-span good morning I have a
comment and a question to the mr. Yusuf
first I I want him my comment is he
mentioned earlier that Islam justify
what bin Laden or his follower or
whoever did this is correct he made it
in a few minutes ago Islam does not
justify any anything like I don't think
I don't think I've said it I said that
bin Laden's uh movement is political is
not religious they're using Islamic
slogan in terms to justify the last for
power right my my second comment is
when you know the hatred against the
West is because the British way back
when they control the Middle East they
gave the Jews from Europe to come and
live in Palestine and that when they
came to live in Palestine they oppressed
the Palestinian people they didn't have
homeland and the fight is goes on for
over 52 years and that is that is not
justifiable and the British who did this
plant in the Middle East they should
build the consequences of their policy
foreign policy the second is our foreign
policy Mary answered Elton will go to
the next point - for me the the problem
of Israel Palestine goes start before
the British Mandate and the declaration
about for under Balfour Declaration
number one number two far more important
bin Laden when he makes the case of
especially including his reaction to the
current to the recent bombing and the
current warned Afghanistan is that he
point to the destruction of the Ottoman
Empire and the West's elimination of the
last Caliphate is the starting point of
the current crisis not disturb lachemann
of the State of Israel Arabs and
Palestinians may have grievances visibly
Israel visibly the West for policy in
the Middle East they may be justified or
unjustified the note point of Connor for
conversation right now but don't put
words in in the mouth of bin Laden bin
Laden and the Islamist grieve grief and
vowed revenge for the destruction of the
Ottoman Empire nothing else Los Angeles
our next caller good morning good
morning um I may have missed it uh but
what state does he believe sponsored the
acts in New York was Iran involved in it
so what will Iran and Iraq do if Ben
Laden is killed okay the investigation
into the events of September 11 is way
the beginning photo early to start
pointing fingers at sponsoring States
and episod
role in that operation beyond noting
that from our knowledge of the way this
individual operate specifically and in
principle he is never carried out in
operation on his own is usually depends
on the professional services
intelligence services of sponsoring
States as far as states in the past I
think I counted there are five state
that have emerged over the the last few
years as the primary sponsors of bin
Laden and these are Syria Iraq Iran
Pakistan and Sudan Afghanistan is an old
country so cannot be counted these
countries are facilitated a lot of his
activities and benefited geostrategic
early from terrorist acts carried in his
name or in the name of Islamist
terrorist movement that he sponsors and
inspires next call Washington DC good
morning good morning the question that I
want to ask is about the popular the
popularity of anti-western sentiment and
the popularity of bin Laden himself in
the Arabic world and the Muslim world
I'd like to know what can be done we
know how we got there probably because
the government's there wanted to offer
diversions from the real issues that
these countries were going through and
the lack of democracy and Free Press but
what can we do now for this anti Western
and anti and probe bin Laden sentiment
be toned down well we must debunk we
must debunk bin Laden's message and we
in order to do that we must find local
powers local religious powers Muslim
powers capable of having the same level
of charisma same level of outspokenness
toward the west in order to be able to
to confront him and debunk the
popularity we need to work with the
local government sometimes we may have
to change government as I said it's far
as a terrorism sponsoring states are
concerned and help them turn inwardly
and abandoned variety of messianic
doctrines that right now dominate their
lives and rebuild
try and bring their own population into
the 21st century and all the benefits
that one can gain from death the New
York Times this morning bill Sapphire
has his column he writes the troubling
part of our strategy is it's blinkered
tidiness we seem to be going after one
terrorist group at a time this we leave
the Hamas and Hezbollah with their
Syrian and Iranian sponsorship off the
list of groups whose assets we freeze
Secretary of State Colin Powell
dismisses this that they're on another
list which is true but disingenuous it's
extremely disingenuous because for
example they bin Laden's number one
until the year 2000 be London's leading
network in Israel for example what's run
by a guy named Oh Cal it was a member of
the farmers was sent by the farmers to
Afghanistan for training when he
returned on behalf of bin Laden in to to
Israel he met with Jefferson the leader
of the farmers and got his initial
funding through the farmers and his
initial recruits were all members of the
farmer secret arms so their own
intellect of all interconnected to try
and separate between the two between
them is like splitting hair and just
doesn't make sense Napa California good
morning for Yosef Adamski good morning
good morning for so much to read I
haven't see you in a long time good to
see you
question for mr. authority there I know
a little very little about the s of
religion but I've turned into some of
the shows you know now talking about the
subject I have two questions does the
Quran support what mr. bin Laden has
been doing no and is it true by the
Koran or by Islam that once they have
lost a territory or lamb they must
reclaim it by means of jihad
the issue for territory lost and reclaim
the the quote master unquote is a very
very vague definition which means that
that in principle yes but there's a
limit to what one can beat individual or
a Muslim country can and should do in
order to reclaim the land committing war
crimes college pillage etc are not on
the list
if it should be a priority but not at
all cost and definitely the are the
goals does not justify the means
Boca Raton Florida good morning to you
hello am I on the air insurance I'd like
to ask if America were to be is as
ruthless as some of our enemies are
their personal treasures such as family
or religious targets that could be
attacked that would pain bin Laden and
his followers or is mr. bin Laden beyond
such concern of his relatives or other
emotional treasures thank you thank you
she is beyond and we should not sink to
that low level next call good morning
where you phoning from hello you're on
the air go ahead caller
yes please I have a car question coming
yes good morning Monica sir you're on
the air go ahead thank you yes it's my
question as all American you know I'm
married to American beautiful ladies and
have a beautiful children and I want to
say this you know America should should
care for American okay if Israel want to
continue the war was the Arab Legion
Keisha author by the name of God or
whatever God they have you know and we
should out of it and it is a mini
country like Denmark Switzerland they
have no problem we have to stop you know
to be a war machine society it's not
working it's hurting us and we be high
price for they for everybody out there
our money go to Israel our money go to
Egypt our money go to Pakistan and then
in in the entity makes trouble for us
and will be high price you know enough
it's enough 'since it should America
should care for the American and America
thanks color
well this is a correlational Spalla sees
it has its merits I think that in the
world of global economy and information
era it's impossible to isolate ourselves
we have to function in the world but we
have to do it realistically Lansing
Michigan good morning Lansing Michigan
hello go ahead please yes just looked at
the recent issue I believe was Harper's
and with Chris Hedges wrong article
seven days in the Palestine refugee camp
after reading this article is you see
any way out of this quagmire of a mess
of putting the two sides together it
seems like there was one two-year-old
who said all I want to do is kill Jews
where I grew up the conditions they live
in they look across and I see how the
other side's living is there any way out
of this quagmire if not I don't see an
internist every problem has a solution
if the site directly involves certain
minds into solving it the main problem
of of the arab-israeli conflict is that
our government have cornered themselves
into a position that there's no solution
other the destruction of Israel and the
establishment of the Palestinian state
in its dead the last money last time
we've seen a manifestation of that
uncompromising policy was that mr. Barak
then Israel's Prime Minister offered mr.
Arafat everything with the exception of
unlimited right of return is the ability
to flood Israel with Palestinians that
will change it demographic character our
faith walked away and started Intifada
that goes now for more than a year and
cost tremendously in life and liberty to
and economic capabilities to the
Palestinians as well of Israel as Israel
when the sides decided they want to
coexist in peace always will be found
perhaps not perfect but ways will be
found to coexist next car Las Vegas good
morning
yeah hello go ahead caller hablas
Podolski how do you take an exception to
that how many actual terrorists you
think are on the list
I do import-export that region we figure
there's six to eight hundred clergymen
with possible following maybe fifty to
seventy thousand now there may be two
and a half million blue-collar work
about believe is that very hardcore now
I said it about a quarter of a million
hardcore supporters of bin Laden's all
over the world and they have about two
two and a half million support elements
that are not ready to kill and die for
the cause but rather support the cause
and this is a fault crime in this
quarter of a million of heart cause far
cry from the quarter of humanity which
is ordinary Muslims would like to live
in coexist in peace with us in running
but Osama bin Laden you say quote he is
a unique man according to a friend who
knows him you can see it in his eyes
he's doing Allah's work like nobody else
pay close attention to him if he's not
martyred soon he'll get far he'll be a
great leader of the jihad because he
fears nobody but Allah you know these
are the words of the individual who
introduced me to bear to - belonging to
the bin Laden name a very farsighted
individual and an Arab much older than
the usual Mujahideen at the time and he
was right and that was when 31 next call
Stowe Vermont good morning good morning
I'd like to ask mr. abinanti a question
about the Israeli involvement in
creating the situation and specifically
American foreign policy that is very
one-sided towards the State of Israel
and I'd like to please to answer the
question and not avoid it like you have
with previous quarters thank you thank
you oh and look we're here discussing
mr. bin Laden odious policy vis-a-vis
the Middle East visibly Israel it is a
complex subject US policy in the Middle
East the numerous interest and one
should stress that the major for example
the lot the most major crisis that we
had in the Middle East in recent years
were the Gulf War in which one air
Iraq invaded quite another country the
longest was little bloody war in the
region was between Iraq and Iran to see
a sisterly Muslim state it was were able
to come and now have a strategic
alliance against common enemies serious
we know oppressing and abusing Lebanon
and other Arab country I mean sister
Arab country the Islamist movement
throughout the Muslim world from Algeria
Libya through Egypt Jordan etcetera been
killing when Tom Lee left and right up
and down Muslims rather than Jews did
the herb Israeli conflict is but one
component albeit very central as far as
the media is concerned this biography on
Osama bin Laden you title it the man who
declared war on America again
before we let you go just briefly go
through his life where he was born how
he rose to power how he was able to
garner the money that he has and where
you think he might be today money Saudi
Arabia and the mid-50s is in his mid
forties right now educated in primarily
injured and westernized education gave
up on on the west out of conviction his
formative years ideologically were in
Afghanistan in the 1980s where he helped
that you heard against the Soviet Union
and was exposed to Abdullah Azzam and
other luminaries of revolutionary Islam
in the early 90s have his major
confrontation with the Saudi government
royal family over the presence of
American troops in Saudi Arabia what's
more important important prevent that
the filing of sacred land by American
forces or the fitting Iraq he thought
that the filing was far more important
spent the next fun getting to know Ayman
al-zawahiri and established functioning
relationship that become close personal
alliance that he still today all of them
the whole bin Laden's over here at
cetera moved to Afghanistan in 1996
where bin Laden rose to becoming his own
man a leader in his own right and
ideological voice to be reckoned with in
1998 he declared war on the United
States formally and hence the title yo
sup Adamski thank you very much for
spending
I'm with us pleasure